the White House playing some defense
over the age-old question haunting the
Biden presidency is the president too
old 77 percent of the country thinks so
saying he wouldn't be very effective if
re-elected but Corinne Jean-Pierre she
is going the extra mile to try to defend
her boss
so you're part of the 23 percent of
adults who is not who are not concerned
about the president's ability to be
president because of his age and stamina
I got it that's because you've got to do
his work but 77 but 77 percent of adults
are worried Joe Biden's been in politics
since before literally since before you
were born and like that he's he's well
aged I'm not saying he's not able to
walk no but no but you're saying you're
talking about his strength right you're
talking about how he's looking right now
I think like the average American male
only lives to be 77. I've I've had
conversations with some of your
colleagues in the White House Press
Corps when we travel abroad how it is
hard for us to keep up with this
president who is constantly constantly
working every day to get things done
Jean-Pierre had more age questions to
deal with thanks to a new insider book
on Biden's presidency it dishes on how
Biden has admitted to AIDS that he felt
tired at times during his first two
years in office and how striking it is
that the president has so few public
events before 10 a.m Kareem Jean-Pierre
brushing off questions on Biden's light
morning routine
is this why we're seeing
wait see that last part do you think
we've had those lit because the because
of this excerpt
so
the book is suggesting the president
tells AIDS he's tired but that's in the
X-ray yeah and that that's why there
have been so few public events before 10
a.m I mean that's a ridiculous
assumption to make and Democratic
candidate RFK Jr no stranger to his own
personal fitness wading into Biden's
Health while walking around with our own
Fitness Guru Jesse Waters his job
uh requires a lot people to be in good
shape and have mental acuity
and I think that if he feels that
he's up to that that he should debate me
do you feel that he's up to debating I'm
not gonna I I don't think it's good for
the American people and I don't think
it's good for the Democratic Party
if the only people that he has to talk
to to win this election are his donors
Jesse I I just going back to binder's
question I like colorbinder and I think
it's cute and I hope that she
understands that that is all in good fun
so I don't understand why she doesn't
say something like the president is wise
the president gives us good guidance but
when she says we can't keep up with him
that's hard to believe that says more
about her and the Press Corps than it
says about Joe Biden that they can't
keep up with him on a plane
I had a brunch lid in college after
drinking all Saturday night I had brunch
on Sunday and shut everything down
that's the Commander in Chief you can't
have brunch lids and be in the White
House they need a new line the line is
well watch him
well we've watched them walk and see him
fall we watched him talk and forget
people's names and we watched him work
we watched him fall asleep in Maui at
the U.N and at the beach they need a new
line because that is not working anymore
especially after we saw those numbers
this guy this author has gotten full
access to the Biden presidency he's seen
the Inner Circle this guy's supposed to
write a favorable piece and it looked
like a hatchet job by the way some of
these excerpts came out he's in mental
decline he's in physical decline it
confirms everything we already knew this
wasn't a revelation this is a
confirmation of everybody that we've
seen throughout the last two and a half
years what I've found pretty striking
was the fact that he said they're
treating me like a child when he went
out there and said we need regime change
in Russia and then everybody cleans it
up the White House staff
and he just lets him clean it up he
can't just come out and announce his own
policy because it's not his it's
somebody else's and that makes you think
who's running it because he's not
running it another excerpt came out
about Afghanistan
they said this guy was being laughed at
by his staff it was his fault the
evacuation went poorly and then he was
proposing things like building a parking
lot to pick up people or then having the
planes leave and then having the planes
come back and pick up more people none
of this was workable so this only tells
me that I've been right the entire time
and it's not a conspiracy theory that
this guy is not in charge and is in
steep decline Pierce do you know
Franklin four the writer of this book I
know of him right and so it's not like
this has come from the right wing no no
right so that's why I think that people
need to understand like this is not a
book that is a hatchet job this is a
book that a writer that they invited
into the White House and gave full
access right but it's this is not about
his age right let's be clear this is not
about Joe Biden being 80. I was an
England cricket match about four weeks
ago England versus Australia you should
come love it guys I'll give you a great
day out you're a lot about this cricket
I'm sitting there and in walks sir Mick
Jagger who had just turned 80. he's
literally seven months younger than Joe
Biden
he is a guy who races around a stage for
two and a half hours a night he never
Falls over he doesn't forget the words
of his lyrics he had a conversation with
me that was absolutely whip smart funny
I even joked you should be president of
the United States he didn't deny the
allegation or the suggestion um and I
did a bit of other Reckoning here so
David Attenborough is 97. do you ever
hear him call a gorilla an antelope no
you don't the queen was 96 Word Perfect
never fell over in public Warren Buffett
is 93 his partner Charlie Munger is 99
when they do their annual address to
their people for hours of end they are
whip smart and were perfect so this is
not about age this is about his ability
to do the job given the condition of
himself mentally and physically and I
think we need to get this debate away
from just he's 80. because other people
will be watching this he'll go my lady
or my dad's 80 or my grandfather's 80
they're not like this this is not how
most 80 year old people are they don't
spend all their time falling over not
the ones I know my dad's 83 doesn't fall
over every two minutes he doesn't forget
the queen actually died yeah and so on
and so on so I think it's uh the debate
is a good debate to have and 69 of
Democrats think he's too old but I think
we need to move away from the fact that
it's because he's 80. well I think
actually the Paul even though they say
to all judge I think it means that
people are understanding because they've
seen with their own eyes and it's not to
make fun of him it's not to ridicule him
it's to say that we are just seeing with
our own eyes and that's the most
demanding job in the world as president
of the United States right and you know
this isn't about the Republicans making
political hay out of the fact that the
president isn't with it I mean it's the
American people 77 of them are concerned
about this President I mean there and
and kjp Korea jump here she's
gaslighting us oh he's go go go we can't
keep up with him I mean when she says
that you can't believe another word out
of her mouth I was a judge I used to say
if someone has lied to you once you
don't have to believe another thing they
say to you during the course of this
trial but you know they took advantage
of him uh and they protected him during
the election coveted in the pandemic
allowed him to come in and you know say
you know I'm energized and I'm vital and
vibrant and we just accepted it you know
on faith but right now we understand
that it isn't as you say uh both Jesse
and and peers it's not about age it's
about mental acuity and it's about the
ability to be able to get things done
and I think the fact that when people
are asked um is he too old to be
president as it relates to Donald Trump
77 percent say Joe Biden is and 51 say
Donald Trump is now that's a 25
difference all right and I believe that
25 difference is due to the fact that
people are looking not at the age but
rather at the mental acuity and and
finally
um you know this whole idea that Works
day and night and all that apparently in
um in this year when there was a problem
with the banks uh Jen sackey gave Biden
kudos for giving a press conference at
nine in the morning no one could believe
it because he usually doesn't show up
until 10 and even then he calls a lid on
it and he grows to International dinners
he doesn't go to the dinners with the
other world leaders because he's too
tired so if he sleeps late and he goes
to bed early what's he doing in the
meantime the other thing is
never heard of a brunch lid because
isn't that quite elitist who has brunch
on a Wednesday I I don't think they
serve it I don't think Cooks know how to
do it on a Wednesday but I have an
interesting story I was at a Yankee game
and then comes Paul McCartney I'm only
kidding so I I mean did you say who are
you I'm gonna yes he said what the hell
are you doing yeah I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do something that Jesse usually
does
I'm just listening to you guys talk and
then putting this together about a month
ago they said it's okay to talk about
Hunter in the Washington Post it's okay
to Democrats to talk about Hunter I
watched Jake Tapper Grill kjp like he's
too old as if he's if he sat down with
Sean Hannity and I'm saying to myself we
get this article from this writer who's
not a right-wing conservative but just
starts allowed to report what they says
and then you see 36 approval rating in
the economy gas up 61 home surprise 11
dead up 33 these numbers are terrible
nobody's even talking about the programs
that he likes no one talks about the war
that he supports there's nothing going
on I almost feel as all these other
Democrats like Westmore Gavin Newsom
Josh Shapiro uh and uh pritzker uh all
fan at Phil Murphy Roy Cooper fan out
across the country allegedly for him I
think they're queuing up his exit and I
was at the White House for something
else three weeks ago two weeks ago and I
heard from two several reporters they
can't believe the decline of this man in
the last month that he is falling off a
cliff if you watch him today you feel
good about what he said the day before
he's losing himself in his own copy
that's right before and right in front
of him he told the fire story about
getting struck by lightning in the
kitchen
again it's unbelievable after he got
crushed for saying that in Maui he
convinced John Thurman to vote for the
Civil Rights Act when he was 21 and not
in the government yeah come on you know
you know what the American people can't
get right now from their president
they can't get no satisfaction no okay
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now